was für eine mondfinsternis oder eben
besser was für ein blut mond und ich
habe euch ja gebeten mir fotos zu
schicken und es waren unmengen ich
wollte sie hier eigentlich unter dem
community posten
aber da hätte ich wohl mit zuges band
deshalb jetzt das video hier und es sind
wirklich spektakuläre fotos angefangen
bei ganz normalen handy fotos bis zu
wirklich unglaublichen hammer fotos die
mit dem teleskop gemacht wurden also los
gehts klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen erstmal vielen
vielen dank für die zahlreichen fotos
die mich über whatsapp und die anderen
messenger erreicht haben damit hätte ich
echt nicht gerechnet die clique und
community hat jemand ein hammer projekt
hingelegt und vielen dank an alle die
mir dann auch die erlaubnis gegeben
haben die fotos zu veröffentlichen
gestern abend war es soweit so ungefähr
je nachdem wo man war um etwa 21 uhr
langsam schob sich der erdschatten vor
dem mond fritze finn hat hier ein klasse
bild gemacht wie sich der erdschatten
hier vor den mond schiebt er noch ist er
hellgrau das sonnenlicht das direkt von
der sonne kommt ist noch zu stark dann
aber liegt der mond schon bald komplett
im erdschatten und nur licht das durch
die erdatmosphäre gebrochen wird und
hier sind die rot anteile viel stärker
das trifft auf dem mond es ist so
eingetreten wie vermutet das
himmelsspektakel dauerte mit 103 minuten
eine ungewöhnlich lange zeit so was wird
in diesem jahrhundert nicht mehr geben
um 21.20 etwa ist die mondscheibe dann
komplett vom erdschatten bedeckt ob
jetzt ist der typisch blutrote
riesengroße mond zu bewundern
in diesem zustand wird der mond auch als
blutmond bezeichnet übrigens wagram und
eben nicht besonders groß was man an den
vielen handy bildern sieht aber er wirkt
groß wenn er zum beispiel hier über der
dresdner frauenkirche zu sehen ist danke
an lena arnold für diese tolle aufnahme
im zweiten bild von ihr ist daran auch
so richtig blutrote es war sogar der
kleinste vollmond des jahres denn er hat
auf seiner bahn um die erde gerade den
größten abstand zu uns und das ist auch
die erklärung für die lange dauer der
mondfinsternis weil der mond so weil er
weiter weg ist länger im erdschatten ist
aber ganz besonders war dann das
erscheinen das maß der dank jetzt viel
dunklere mondes richtig gut zu erkennen
war
und hier sieht man auf dem bild von
jahren aus südhessen so
die erdkrümmung unseres globus als
schatten auf dem mond was für ein
spektakel
hier nochmal die schönsten bilder musik
hoch
ich kann nur sagen gänsehaut pur wenn er
in zukunft kein video verpassen wollen
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht
er die etwas unzuverlässige abo box hier
auf youtube und er verpasst kein video
denn wie whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür da klicken aber nicht die
wenn auch die glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufsteht
menschen sollen auf dem mond siedeln bis
dann bleibt dran